diane coursol est en pleine forme
difficile de croire qu'elle a été opérée
pour le cancer du poumon il y à peine un
mois et demi elle a reçu son congé de
l'hôpital le lendemain de sa chirurgie
la fin de semaine suivante en italien
souper chez des amis ce que j'aurais
probablement pu faire si j'avais eu
l'opération traditionnelle dans la
majorité des cas à l'heure actuelle on
retire une tumeur cancéreuse au poumon
en faisant une incision de 25 cm au
thorax et en cassant des côtes du
patient une technique qui entraîne un
séjour à l'hôpital de plusieurs jours
une convalescence de plusieurs semaines
un nouveau procédé mis au point par une
équipe de chercheurs du chum vient
changer la donne
la chirurgie assistée par vidéo ou ne
nécessite que de petites incisions il
artères pulmonaires est ensuite scellé
grâce à un pistolet à ultrasons ce qui
diminue les risques d'hémorragie
en fait le même occasion dans mais la
plupart et ses passions kit locales dans
les mains puis normalement retourner le
binôme entre les deux semaines qui est
complètement révolutionnaire comparer la
technique traditionnelle
je trouve que la convalescence de cette
méthode lourd nous permet d'être
beaucoup plus actifs après de reprendre
nos activités
des essais cliniques ont été menés sur
150 patients au canada aux états unis et
au royaume uni pour tester l'efficacité
de la nouvelle procédure
les résultats sont concluants le
technique était très secoué a été
équivalent aux vieilles calculs
techniques traditionnelles donc il n'y
avait pas plus de saignements avec cette
nouveauté
cet autre patiente qui a bénéficié de la
nouvelle procédure a participé aux
essais cliniques
je n'aurai pas besoin de chimio ils ont
enlevé tout ce qui avait comme tâche de
cancer tout est parti tout et disparus
c'est de l'histoire ancienne et on
continue ici olivier bachar radio canada
montréal